hey I'm Kevin or am i Kevin no I'm
Jackie hope you did hey I'm Tony
Bancroft I'm the co-director of Disney's
animated Mulan and I created Pumbaa and
crong
hi I'm Kyra I'm the lead animator the
good advice cupcake and the voice -
today we're gonna be drawing what are we
drawing Jason we're drawing Disney
Princesses that's pretty cool I didn't
know that I don't know the subjects
until I actually start drawing you guys
I don't know if you know that but first
be sure to stick around to the end of
the video to find out how you can enter
for a chance to win this medium Wacom
Intuos tablet courtesy of our good
friends at welcome knock knock who's
there interrupting our dropping out who
you're supposed to interrupt me
oh that's hardware you don't know how a
joke right you go first you see nothing
wait come on knock knock who's there
interrupting ell what are we doing I
swear to God really yeah but not down
not down whatsoever you did caught us
worries I did Cogsworth yeah so if you
put Cogsworth in a dress that might be
what my drawing looks like this sheet of
ice queen or a she the sister ice one
okay like front of the DVD box
oh you like am old school yeah well I
mean I just I like her aesthetic the
most okay so Tony how was your
experience on Beauty and the Beast I was
actually an animating assistant when I
first started on being the bees and got
I rose up to being an animator so it was
like a big promotion for me but more
than that I just really loved the story
I mostly was doing comedy characters
that Disney anyway and so I did
Cogsworth the clock I'm being in the
beasts I just had a great time
that film it's one of my favorite Disney
movies it is mine and I've seen at a
time and I love that and I have no idea
what she looks like
in this I've only seen the first movie
and I thought it was just okay she does
hold on she does like the lake yeah walk
out the door and she has like Iceman
powers right yeah she's like Iceman from
x-men I'll put it in the context you can
understand it
Jackie how you been you are you got a
new job I got a new job
what are you doing I work as a
storyboard revisionists okay I work on a
show called centaur world
shout out to my crew on centaur world
yeah I love you guys
well that's very exciting I can't wait
to see it Thanks it'll come out one day
yeah a lot of people don't know how long
it takes to make an animated show it
takes a long time you know what else
takes a long time to make this show
everybody's so impatient when's the next
drop coming out when's the next draw
coming up well here it is friends
heavens tired of your so Tony is there
any tips that you can give in terms of
Disney Princess construction it's funny
asset because a lot of people think that
the Disney Princesses look very similar
and that the Disney basically can only
draw like that one Ariel type glen keane
kind of looking female heroine but there
are there's actually quite a little
quite a bit of difference I think when
you look at the design of these girls
the big thing is you know they tend to
have big eyes right and features very
low on their face I would say and they
all end up looking like Cogsworth after
I draw them that saves you have you seen
frozen you know I saw the first frozen
movie and I was not a fan but I'm also
like not the demographic right but I saw
it because everyone's just like oh my
god frozen it's incredible it's like
watch it I like cartoons he doesn't like
a good cartoon and then I saw it know
like how i sees the oscar-nominated
frozen - I did not see that one did you
see it yeah it was very bad
I'm not afraid to say that on camera
I was snow white for Halloween and I
don't remember how
draw her since we can't really remember
maybe we should just try to ape the
Disney style as much as possible what
makes you think I know anything about
the Disney style no didn't you draw
Disney characters growing up I drew
Naruto growing up no that's kind of
hokey I hope I didn't I didn't like
Disney Princesses that much you know
what neither did I well I think it's
because when I was a kid I was like I'm
not like the other is that how you spoke
when you were okay yeah it was really
scary I had something wrong with me no
wonder you weren't like the other girls
I'm not like the other girls I have a
irritable bowel syndrome kara do you
have a favorite Disney movie from I'm
were you a fan of that like the 90s era
of Disney films I love like every Disney
movie it's so hard to choose which one's
my favorite I really love lilo and
Stitch The Lion King
really like the Aristocats to Aristocats
yeah people don't mention the Aristocats
enough I think that's uh that's one of
my favorites too just from a design
standpoint so Jackie yeah do you
remember all seven of the doors name oh
okay
sad happy depressed anxiety mm-hmm IPS
two more overwatch and
dopey you got it all so baby you got it
did you grow up singing the songs did
you have a princess dress I loved you
really did really just saying that no
really that's what I got excited when I
found out that you animated on him what
was it that you liked about concert
though because he's not the normal thing
no I was like a really small child and I
just like thought he was really cute so
have you been since last season oh my
god Jason I haven't seen you since
was it December I have not seen each
other at all since that time it's been
agony being apart from you two so
there's gonna be honest yeah I call I
text oh wow mater I can't reach you
don't know how wife is screening your
text message you know being so taluk
it's really hard for me when the Cintiq
is really low so the nice thing about
welcome is that they they have a great
design here to be able to really bring
it up high so that I know I can get down
to the bottom of the shoes on bill that
really helps save a little bit of back
does this baby dink
don't got no back what was it like
directing I'm Mulan you know it's like a
real roller coaster for me as an artist
I really love that opportunity and and
grew so much and yet being kind of
having to deal with management issues
that was the tough part because in art
school you know they don't teach you
anything about how to manage a group but
I got into it and I just loved the cast
and crew you know they the directors
don't don't do the hard work anyway it
really is about the artists and the
other animators that was the gate
shouting and so you audience members
can't see our final drawings until we
switch yes they're just tapping away
what's going on you know I like resorted
to pointillism a new a new expressionist
art style yeah I like it
I'm like like this new development is
actually making my drawing look better
so I know that you're working on Space
Jam too
what can you tell us about it very
little without killing you Kira OH
keep it brief I doubt yes they are
making a spaceship too and that has been
announced so I'm super excited to be a
part of it times how do you think you
did I think I did oh it looks like a
bootleg snow-white that you would find
on a backpack in a dollar store part of
the draw-off off-brand character
universe yeah I think she should be the
president
okay you guys register to vote I think I
did all right
the eyes are a little weird so that's
the first thing you're gonna roast me
for I like roasted carrots and roasted
cauliflower those are my two favorite
roasted vegetables you know what I drew
a callable character that has a blue
dress okay and great hair no what about
you what do you think like I said I
think this looks more like a cartoon
character cosplaying Belle but like
she's cute I feel like I got the essence
of her but very off muddled okay well
well now I'm jealous
you like elevated elephant Marvel
presents Elsa the badass and this is
like her hair it looks like this I
totally forgot that there is this long
braid you really remind this is what she
looks like and why I like it clicked the
second I saw this Oh aren't that creepy
okay I get some Jackie applause 3-amp
love it yours of course
is super cute think it's very Jackie I
will say I think her shoulder things are
white and not yellow do you think so I
think so oh you're probably right oh my
gosh
we yeah you know what we did some kind
of similar we were both channeling she
loves books all right literally
channeled like this like same sort of
pose and everything I love yours yours
is so adorable and structured though it
looks so professional No No thank you
but I appreciate your kindness yeah yeah
yeah she's got exposed her shoulders
yeah this is like cosplay Elsa I think
someone would put that yeah if they were
designing it okay thank you her sleeves
are
like wow yeah we both messed that up I
forgot that like there's so many animals
involved yeah but like I remember she
liked to sing to them she goes like ah
and the birds come that is a wonderful
rendering thank you ever so
oh okay you know what I feel proud of us
yeah I think we did pretty good we're in
the same wavelength I must admit you you
got a far closer I feel like and on top
of it did not work on the film so if
there's got to be a win I think it goes
your way no there's no way we're coming
great work Jackie thank you I think we
both did okay for a character that is 83
years old I think we do all right
she looks great for 83 you're doing all
right Snow White no wait here's to
looking at you kid okay if you want to
enter for a chance to win this Wacom
Intuos medium tablet courtesy of our
good friends at welcome all you have to
do is go to the official draw off show
Instagram that's at draw off show find
this post and follow the instructions
knock knock who's there
h/h you walked right under that one do
you just dab who dabs I do okay I do all
right
[Music]